the religion of Islam is as diverse as
any other religion the many ways that
Muslims have and still do conceptualize
and understand their religion is after
all what makes the religion what it is
and among the many schools and branches
of Islam one of the most influential and
significant in history have been the
group known as the ismailis being the
second largest branch of shi Islam to be
precise the ismailis have often received
a lot of criticism from other Muslims
from sunnis as well as she is but a lot
of these criticisms are often based on
huge misrepresentations and
misunderstandings So today we're instead
going to attempt a general overview of
the ismailis both on their own terms but
also on the terms of modern historical
scholarship so who then are the ismailis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Islam is often described as being
divided into three very general branches
the Sunni Shia and sometimes the ibadi
this division can be somewhat
anachronistic especially when talking
about the earliest periods of Islamic
history but it can help us Identify some
major historical movements and the
ismailis are she Muslims they are the
second largest branch of shiism
generally and have been very significant
both on an intellectual slash religious
and political level historically and
today
producing some of the greatest
philosophers and Scholars in Muslim
history as well as ruling some of the
largest Empires the ismailis have shaped
the so-called Islamic world to a major
degree in general terms ismaili shiism
can be characterized as an esoteric
movement within Islam on both doctrinal
and practical levels they have
emphasized a certain level of
esotericism as we will see and their
theological and philosophical ideas very
strongly adopted a neoplatonic model in
particular
we'll get to all of this fastening stuff
in due time but first we need to cover
the basics where do these Smileys come
from and what is their history
again the ismailis are Shi Muslims she
is in itself is divided into various
branches and schools that can differ on
a number of points the even more General
division of Islam into Sunni and Shia
has at its core a debate over Authority
they all believe in the prophecy of
Muhammad and the revelation of the Quran
but after the prophet died who was
supposed to succeed him and in what way
the group that would later come to be
known as Sunni believe that political
Authority was passed on to chosen
members of Muhammad's Community the or
calebs and eventually accepted as
righteous so-called the first four Abu
Bakr Omar uthman and Ali later
caliphates like the Umayyads and
abbasids were often considered
legitimate leaders as representatives of
the prophet and God but are not revered
in the same way as the first four in
terms of religious or Spiritual
Authority the sunnis would come to
recognize the community of Scholars the
so-called as a source of authority on
Law and belief as well as the Sufi
sheikhs and Saints especially in later
periods
the Shia had a different view instead
they held that authority to lead the
community was passed down in the
prophet's family
first in a more General sense of being
part of the hashimi clan but later
becoming narrowed down specifically to
the Alid family line the progeny of
Muhammad's daughter Fatima and Ali his
cousin Ali became the first so-called
Imam of the shiis and plays an enormous
role in their Theology and doctrines
the title of Imam or rightful leader was
then passed down from Ali to his son
Hassan then his brother Hussein and then
continued in a line of patrilineal's
succession in the earliest period there
were many debates around rightful
Authority in the Muslim Community we can
in no way talk about a simple Shia Sunni
divide at this time these communities as
fixed identities wouldn't be formulated
until many centuries later instead there
were many different claimants to
Authority both politically on on
religiously some of whom legitimized
their rules simply on power or other
factors While others like the alids for
example did So based on their direct
familial connection to the prophet early
shiism is a difficult topic with many
competing accounts but it seems that it
was in many ways a kind of Messianic
movement many imams so sons of Ali and
their sons and their sons Etc who
claimed Authority and gained followers
but according to later established Shia
Doctrine there is a certain line of
imams that is considered correct or
authoritative any later division of
shiism into further branches is
determined by which line of imams a
certain Community sees as true or
legitimate
in shiism there has to always be an Imam
in the world a person who has been given
the knowledge to interpret the Quran and
Sunnah of the prophet in the correct way
and adapt it to new situations and times
the Imam is given this knowledge by the
previous Imam his father who received it
from the Imam before him and so on this
direct appointment of the new Imam by
the previous one the continuing of the
Lion of imams is called Nas and is
Central to Shia belief
theit or family of the Prophet Muhammad
has been given the role to lead his
community through their intimate and
direct knowledge of the essence of the
quranic message
it's not that the Quran is incomplete
per se as I mistakenly alluded to in a
previous video but the Quran requires
there to be an Imam who has the Gnostic
or infallible knowledge of its meaning
so that he can interpret it for the
Muslims
the she is criticized their proto-sunic
counterparts for relying too much on
their own minds and their own rational
thoughts in interpreting and
understanding religion which led to
division and confusion regarding beliefs
and practices
instead to she is there is always an
Imam a possessor of full knowledge who
has the authority to interpret the
religion and to adapt it to New Times
and circumstances and according to the
major schools there is always only one
Imam at any given time so the religious
and spiritual essence of Shia Islam
always revolve around a single pole a
single point that determines all other
points and aspects and this is true for
all prophetic Cycles earlier prophets
like Moses or Jesus also had imams that
succeeded them there simply cannot be
any religion without any mom to lead
them the shiis will even say that there
can't be a time at all when there is no
Imam and that even if there are only two
people left alive in the world one of
them will be the Imam thus this doctrine
of the imamit so-called is at the core
of all Shia belief and spirituality it
is the main point that distinguishes
them from the sunnis even though they
have developed any other unique features
and differences over the years too
and again the main difference between
different branches of shiism is that
they accept different lines of imams as
correct
the two largest branches the twelver or
ishary and the ismailis all agree on the
first six imams Ali the son-in-law and
cousin of the Prophet is the first Imam
he was followed by his son Hassan the
Imam was then inherited by his brother
Ali's other son Hussein after Hussein
was martyred in the Battle of karbala in
680 and even that would become a central
aspect of Shia Consciousness and believe
later on his son Ali Zain and abedin
became the next Imam followed by his son
Muhammad al-baqir and finally the last
Imam that they all accept as canonical
is jaffar assadic
is one of the most significant of the
imams regardless of which branch of
shiism you are talking about and for
various reasons the imams in general are
thought to be the carriers and source
for much of Islamic esotericism and even
occultism sometimes and Jafar plays a
major role here but also of course in
the succession of imams because after
his death there appeared two different
groups one who considered jaffa's older
son is smiled to be the rightful
successor and another group that didn't
although sources on both sides indicate
that he had indeed been chosen as the
next Imam there is disputes over this
because Ismail had reportedly died
before his father the other group
instead considered the younger son Musa
al-kazam to be the next Imam and they
eventually became known as the twelver
or Shiites which we have already
dedicated a full episode to the first
group though still believed that Ismail
had been the true successor to jaffar
assadek since he had been appointed the
next Imam by his father and they argued
the imams are after all infallible so he
wouldn't make a mistake like that
they thus looked to ismail's living son
Muhammad IBN Ismail as the next Imam
that had been chosen by a smile before
his death this General group is the one
that became known as the Smileys right
because they are named after Ismail the
oldest son of Jafar asada and they of
course as the talent suggest would be
the main focus of this episode even in
this earliest period there were many
different variants of ismail's followers
some believe that Muhammad IBN Ismail
had gone into occultation and that he
was the coming Mahdi
others believe that there were
hereditary imams that followed him imams
who had simply gone into hiding because
of the persecution from the Abbasid
caliphs the first of these groups are
often known as the seveners and would
eventually turn into groups like the
famous carnations a revolutionary group
who created a kind of State in eastern
Arabia and during the 9th and 10th
centuries strongly opposed the Abbasid
regime by among other things and very
controversially sacking the city of
Mecca and stealing the Black Stone from
the Kaaba this is a very interesting and
significant episode of course but we
should remember that the carnations do
not represent the majority of the
proto-ismailis at the time not even also
called seveners
regarded them as legitimate or accepted
them so to say but this is a very
significant and important episode in the
early history of Islam and of course
also in ismailism to a certain degree
and it was indeed another group of
ismailis that would prove most
successful namely the group who believed
that the mom succeeding Muhammad IBN
Ismail were still alive because in 899
one of the central leaders of the
ismaili community in Syria Ali IBN and
Hussein publicly emerged to claim his
identity as the actual Imam the
hereditary successor to Muhammad IBN
Ismail and the rest thus making him the
11th Imam of the ismailis it is this
Imam who later went under the name
Abdullah that subsequently founded the
Fatimid Empire which would come to rule
major portions of the Islamic World from
their base in Egypt thus making ismaeli
sheism a major player on the political
scene the major impact of the fatimids
made sure that it was their ismailism
that became the dominant for the rest of
History
during the rule of this major Empire the
caliphs or political leaders were also
the imams of the ismailis giving them a
kind of double title of caliph imams so
they were both the political leaders of
a vast Empire the Fatimid caliphate of
Fatimid Empire but also the spiritual
pole of ismailism at the time right the
highest spiritual and religious leader
to the ismaili community so they were
the most important person in the world
in two respects these Smileys have
always been very active in the
intellectual sphere producing some
really significant and great thinkers in
history developing many uh
groundbreaking and significant ideas in
the history of Islamic thought and this
early period is no different as the
Fatimid caliphate grew in science and
the caliph imams became very powerful
they sent out missionaries and Scholars
to spread the ismaili Creed producing
figures like Abu yakub and suggestani
hamidadin kirmani and Nasir khusro most
Scholars today also agree that the
mysterious anonymous group known as the
echuanas Safa the Brethren of Purity
where is smiley Shiites although they
might have belonged to the sevener group
that deny the fatimid's claim to the
imams but this is still uncertain but
because their major attacks these
so-called Epistles of the Brethren of
Purity were so popular and influential
for much of the Middle Ages and partly
because they were Anonymous even many
Sunni thinkers admired them and Drew
from their ideas so in this way is
smiley thinkers and ideas have had a
major impact on all corners of the
Islamic faith and its intellectual
tradition the fatimids were one of the
most major empires in the history of the
Islamic world having a major impact on
its trajectory not only did it obviously
shape the world of shiism by giving one
of its major branches full political
power but it also shaped the Sunni world
it is in large part because of the power
of the fatimids on both the political
and religious intellectual level that we
see major Sunni institutions and figures
start to develop a kind of Sunni
Orthodoxy that didn't really exist in
the same way before figures like
for example very important for the
formulation of what we know as Sunni
Orthodoxy today right he writes all of
his works his whole sort of project is
partly based on trying to refute the
power of these Smileys to say that oh we
need to make sure we know who we are
right we need to draw the boundaries of
what sunism is to differentiate it from
from the sheets from the ismailis right
so the fatimids and the ismailis are
very important in that sense for the
very creation of this idea of of Sunni
Islam as we know it today this period is
often called the Sunni Revival but in
many ways it's almost really like the
birth of sunniism as we know it because
this is the first time that all these
different schools of Sunni law for
example start to see each other as part
of a single whole which was not
necessarily the case before we should
probably spend a dedicated episode to
exploring the Fatimid caliphate in
particular but it is certainly a major
part of ismaili History the father myths
are known for having sponsored and
helped art forms like architecture art
music and science flourish minority
groups like Christians and Jews were
generally treated with a relatively open
attitude and treated well and Fatimid
Society the fatimate also founded the
City of Cairo and kahira in Arabic as
their capital a role that that City
cannot retains even to this day
they also founded and built the
al-azhara mosque or university which
ironically has become perhaps the most
major center of learning for Sunni Islam
to this day
in short the fatimids had a major impact
on the Islamic World while representing
the high point of a smiley political
influence the caliph imams of the
ismailis ruled from the early 10th
Century until 1171 when the empire was
overthrown by the famous salahuddin or
Saladin but even while in political
power these Smileys were of course not
immune to the many schisms that often
appeared regarding the succession line
of the imams towards the end of the
Fatimid Empire there appeared many such
debates over who the rightful successor
was who the next Imam was supposed to be
to a certain killif Imam for example
after the rule of the 18th Imam and the
eighth Fatimid caliph al-mustan's there
was another split some of whom believed
that his rightful successor was the
older son nidar who was according to
them robbed of the throne by his brother
al-mustali who became who actually
became the next caliph thus we see the
ismailis being split into two more
branches the nizari ismailis and those
who followed al-mustali which eventually
turned into the group known as the taibi
ismailis which today is represented by
communities like the dawoodi boras and
aladiboras in India as well as the
so-called suleimanis in Yemen for a
third discussion of the taibi ismailis
in particular you can check out an
earlier episode that I've dedicated
specifically to that but for most of
history since then the other group the
so-called Nissan ismailis have been the
majority and for that reason they will
kind of be the main focus of this video
even though we will of course touch on
the taibi beliefs and practices later
too but the nazadis will be the main
focus of this episode but before we
continue our exploration of ismaili
History we should probably get into some
of the juicy details about a smiley
belief philosophy and practice what is
it that makes ismailism so unique the
fatimate empire in the Middle Ages is a
very significant period for for the
intellectual history of ismailism partly
of course because we have many sources
from that time because when the smiles
were given political power there was a
lot more room to develop uh well to
to produce writings but also to develop
intellectual ideas and so on but also
because it is at this time that some of
the most significant philosophers and
Scholars in the smiley history appear
and shape the the thought world of these
smilies to a major degree indeed the
ismailis have carved out a very unique
position in Islam in terms of their
beliefs and philosophy one that is
unique even compared with other Shi
branches they share many of the features
already discussed with other branches of
shiism such as the prominence of the
Imam for all religious matters it is the
Imam who is the true successor to
Muhammad who knows the secrets and true
meanings of the Quran and thus decides
all matters of religious practice and
belief based on that internal knowledge
the difference from say the 12 verse is
that these Smileys had an Imam present
in the world for a much longer period in
the case of the nazadis they still have
a living Imam today
this means that in the case of the
majority in the Saudis there has always
been an Imam at the center of the
religion who has absolute Authority
these imams and these Scholars who
represent them often known as dais
missionaries and in the most exalted
examples are called hujots or proofs
shaped and formed the doctrines of
ismailism including its unique Theology
and jurisprudence to start with the
fascinating topic of theology the
ismailis have a long and deep tradition
being Muslims they adhere to the basic
teachings of Islam they are monotheists
believing in one God and that Muhammad
is the final prophet of that God
the uniqueness of ismaili theology is
the strictness of their monotheism
in some ways you could argue that they
are the branch of Islam that have the
most rigorous and unforgiving
understanding of monotheism what does
this mean well at its core is smiley
theology heavily adapted the
philosophical tradition known as
neoplatonism as the basis for much of
its theology now most Muslim
intellectuals were influenced by
neoplatonism in some way but these
Smileys adapted this system to a much
larger degree and in this neoplatonic
understanding of Islam they identified
god with the one at the top of platinian
metaphysics
for those of you who aren't familiar
with this tradition this means that they
see God as an unfathomable Oneness or
Simplicity that transcends all being and
non-being or any possible categories
that can be humanly conceived this is a
theology that is radically apathetic a
negative Theology of the most extreme
sort apathetic or negative theology
means an understanding of God where
nothing can be said positively about God
positive in terms of a positive
statement not like saying something is
good right if anything the only things
we can say are the things that God are
not for example God is not limited he is
not ignorant he is not weak Etc this
apathetic theology is a kind of position
or approach associated with many famous
figures in history like maimonides
Thomas Aquinas as well as many Islamic
theologians and philosophers across
history however these Smileys go even
further in their epiphaticism as we will
see in Islamic theology there has always
been a discussion of about God's
attributes and qualities
in the Quran God is described as being
powerful as being merciful he is hearing
he is seeing Etc in some ways this
seemed to clash with another basic
Assumption of Islam which is the
incomparability of God to any creatures
or created things that he's unlike
anything in creation or anything that
can be conceived not only this but God
is also supposed to be the pure one
whose Oneness excludes all Multiplicity
but all these attributes and names seem
to apply a kind of Multiplicity in God
if God is the merciful and the powerful
if he has life and knowledge and hearing
and seeing this seems to compromise the
Simplicity and Oneness of God's nature
because they become kind of parts of God
and absolute Oneness or Simplicity
cannot be made up of Parts because of
this they erupted many theological
debates and schools in Islam to figure
out just how this seeming Paradox worked
some such as these so-called hanbalis
choose to accept these statements in the
Quran about God however anthropomorphic
they may seem and simply state that we
cannot understand just how he has these
attributes it's often a Doctrine called
billah cave without how so they will say
that well yeah God has a hand because
the Quran says that God has a hand but
we cannot understand in what way or in
what mode he has that hand others such
as the mohitasilla see these attributes
not as parts of God's Essence but as
identical to his Essence think of it
like this God does not have power he is
power God doesn't have life he is life
and so on
to them this maintained the Oneness of
God's Essence without negating the
attributes completely other schools such
as the mainstream ashadis and maturity
schools in Sunni Islam basically take
the middle position where the attributes
are both part and not part of God in
some way the smileys on the other hand
would have none of this to them the
monotheism Oneness and Transcendence of
God could not be compromised to affirm
attributes in God is equal to a kind of
hidden or subtle polytheism of believing
in multiple gods all quranic verses that
describe god with human categories have
to be read metaphorically even the
central attributes like life knowledge
will power hearing seeing and speaking
even the who deny the independence of
the attributes were guilty of this kind
of subtle or hidden polytheism to these
Smileys nothing can be said about God
with perhaps the exception of saying
that he is right as he completely
transcends all contingent categories
here we obviously see their very strong
epiphaticism but they go even further by
also negating negative statements about
God too
one of the most famous and important
ismaili Scholars and philosophers in
history
discusses this topic in his jamiel
hechmatein the union of the two wisdoms
quote
now we have shown clearly on what
grounds it is wrong to describe God by
such attributes as ignorance or
non-knowledge and powerlessness not
powerful not because they are unseemly
but because they are attributes of
creatures as well that is also wrong to
ascribe the Opposites of such attributes
such as knowledge and power to him glory
be to him he is exalted on the ground
that these two are creature equalities
we cannot describe god with attributes
like being powerless but neither can we
describe him as being not powerless
because both these categories are
creaturely qualities it is words used to
describe created things and thus cannot
be true of God who completely transcends
all such connections and because any
such description would compromise his
Oneness or utter Simplicity this is thus
a kind of double negative theology the
most radical of its sorts in the Islamic
tradition God is Not wise but neither is
he not wise it is a collapse of all
attempts at understanding the nature of
God in order to keep him totally exalted
and Transcendent above creative things
to the ismailis this is the only proper
way that God can be approached according
to the principles of reason or akal in
Arabic which is a central part of
religion to them accepting the reality
of God's attributes in the way that
other schools did was according to them
akin to this kind of hidden or subtle
polytheism and and the smiley fingers
often call out other schools as being
precise to that as being
anthropomorphists and literalists if you
know your neoplatonic philosophy you'll
recognize a lot of this stuff the way
that the ismailis talk about the
complete apathetic nature of God is
basically the same way that platinus and
the neoplitness talks about the
so-called one right the tohen in in
Greek and the ismailis also add that
many other aspects of the neoplatonic
system the philosophy of neoplatonism
associated with figures like platinus
particularly has at its core an idea
that reality
emanates right it starts at this concept
of the one tohen that this other
apathetic darkness that cannot be
understood that is other Simplicity from
which everything emanates or emerges and
the first thing that emanates from this
one is something called The Noose in
Greek which is often translated with
things like into intellect is the most
popular translation but can also be
translated things like mind
Consciousness sometimes it's a very
difficult
word to translate because none of those
terms really captures what it means but
it has
affinities with all of those Concepts in
English right and this no so intellect
then emanates something called the
universal soul
and the soul in this case then also
emanates or creates not creates but it
it from the soul the World of Nature and
the world as we know it comes to be
right the four elements the the world in
terms of a temporal physical place with
various modifications and variations
this is the basic system and idea behind
a neoplatonic metaphysics in ismaili
theology God is as we've seen identified
with the one which emanates or
originates the intellect and so on the
intellect called akal in Arabic is seen
in different ways in smilism but is
often identified with the prophetic
light the Nur muhammadiya or the
knowledge on which all prophecy and
Revelation is based as we will see it is
identified with the speech Kalam of God
or in quranic terminology with the pen
the Alam which writes on the tablet the
Lao which is then identified with the
Universal Soul
in Arabic the soul is referred to as the
nephea other quranic terms for these
Concepts include identifying the
intellect with the throne or arch of God
and the Universal Soul with the
footstool the so-called kurusi from this
Soul the tablets in chronic terms is
created the universe as we know it but
the ismailis also made some unique
Innovations to near platonic philosophy
for example aside from the basic
structure of the one intellect Soul the
ismaili thinkers also added the category
of God's command in between God himself
as the originator mobdya and the
intellectual we do find a similar idea
in patanus and earlier new platonic
thinkers which is often referred to in
English as the pre-noetic e-flux why is
this kind of concept in between the one
and the nose which is kind of part of
the Noose or intellect but also not it's
it's a difficult thing in any case this
command is a primordial origination that
seemed to help separate God in his
absolute form from anything that is
originated from him according to the
scholar fadha daftari quote hence God is
the originator or the mobadi and his
command or word act as an intermediary
between him and his Creation The
Universal intellect akal is the first
originated being
also called simply the first and the
preceder sabek since the Amar or logos
is united with it in existence
the intellect is eternal motionless and
perfect both potentially and actually it
corresponds to the number one and in
keeping with the neoplatonic tradition
it is called the source of all light
from the intellect proceeds through
emanation the soul or the Universal Soul
also referred to as the second ethani
and the follower atali corresponding to
the epsiche of the near platonists but
not everyone agreed with this for
example the ismaili philosopher
hamidadian kirimani one of the most
important Scholars of the Fatimid era
rejected this concept of the armor as an
intermediary and also adapted a system
of 10 intellects descending from the one
to the created World perhaps influenced
by philosophers like al-farabi this
almost Gnostic system came to have a
major importance in taibi ismailism in
particular but not as much for other
branches and this is important to
remember that is smiley thought and
philosophy is not something static there
isn't a particular set of beliefs that
they all held or hold but the scholarly
tradition of ismailism is always an
ongoing discussion and development that
by the scholars and imams even to this
day but all these neoplatonic features
and Theological Tendencies of course
have a major impact on things like
prophecy and Revelation now the ismailis
agree with all other Muslims that the
Quran is a manifestation of the speech
of God but they also have a pretty
unique perspective on Prophecy and
Revelation because God is completely
Transcendent Beyond creaturely qualities
he cannot speak in the sense of words
using the new platonic model it is the
intellect that is identified as the
speech of God but this is a non-verbal
speech it is simply an unfathomable
Consciousness or mind perhaps which
contains all of God's knowledge
now in the Quran there is this concept
known as the umal kitab the mother of
the book which is seen as a kind of
heavenly archetype of Revelation
including for the Quran
and again to these Smileys the umal
kitab is interpreted to mean the
intellect in neopatonic terms this means
that what the prophet does including
Muhammad is not that he is given literal
words by an Angel that is received
directly from God instead the prophet is
given Revelation through a quote light
that descends upon his heart he doesn't
receive words as such but is rather
given a kind of vision or direct
correspondence with the intellect with
the umal kitab of quranic terms the
source for all Divine knowledge it is
then the prophet himself that formulates
that non-verbal Revelation or speech
into actual words and sentences that are
relevant to the community he speaks to
in other words the prophet is here given
a much larger role in the process of
Revelation the Quran is still the speech
of God or the manifestation of the
speech of God but the words themselves
are the inspired words of the prophets
as they interpret the non-verbal
Revelation into a human language this is
indeed a rather unique perspective on
Revelation one that is quite distinct
from other theories by other schools and
branches of Islam but it does lead to
many other
significant ideas and points within a
smiley thought because the prophet plays
such an important role in the
formulation of the text of the Quran
itself that also means that he plays a
much more major role in the
interpretation and implementation of
that scripture to the community so to
say being the so-called walking Quran
the prophet Muhammad is the only one who
knows the true inner actual meanings of
the quranic chapters and verses and very
importantly especially too she Islam
that knowledge or elim of the actual
meanings of the Quran is then given
specifically to Ali the first Imam of
the shis and then the knowledge is
handed down from Ali to the next Imam
who ends down to the next Imam and so on
thus this helps explain further why the
imams are so significant to the sheaves
and to the ismailis in particular
because they hold the keys to the true
understand Links of the Quran because
the prophet is the only one who knows
these true understandings and that
knowledge is then transmitted through
this line of Imam so the Imam is the
only person who can truly interpret the
Quran properly and sort of apply it to
new situations and and this was true of
all prophets just like other Muslims the
ismailis believed that various prophets
had been sent to mankind across history
with essentially the same message or
truth in particular these Smileys
divided history into seven eras or
periods each new era or cycle is started
or inaugurated by a speaker Prophet a
natak a messenger who brings a new
revelation and especially a new
religious law or Sharia that replaces
the law of the previous messenger these
six speaker prophets are Adam Noah
Abraham Moses Jesus and lastly Muhammad
whose era is the current one and whose
Sharia is in place currently each such
Prophet all also has a succeeding line
of imams that is responsible for keeping
the message of that prophet and his law
alive so for example the figure of job
was one of the imams of the prophetic
era of Abraham and John the Baptist was
the last Imam in the era of Moses before
the prophethird of Jesus the imams of
Muhammad the sixth speaker Prophet was
Ali and the succeeding land from his
progeny as we have seen the seventh and
last cycle will be inaugurated by
al-qahim a Messianic figure who will
bring the day of Resurrection but often
in ismailism this is interpreted
esoterically not to mean the actual end
of the world but the start of a new
phase of spiritual Revolution when the
outer forms of the Sharia or Islamic law
associated with Muhammad will be
replaced by a revealing of the truths of
religion when the esoteric true meanings
of faith and law is revealed and the
community lives in a heightened
spiritual state no longer in need of an
outer Sharia to access the inner
meanings and truths and this concept of
the hidden meanings or secrets of
Revelation is a Cornerstone of ismaili
beliefs
it is often thought that the Quran
contains outer literal meanings called
as well as hidden or esoteric meanings
baten most schools of Islam have some
concept of these categories but the
shiis are unique in that they have
always put a major emphasis on that
second aspect the baten or esoteric
aspects of scripture and religion that
there are hidden meanings the true
meanings in fact in Scripture that can
be interpreted using a technique known
as tawil which is usually translated
simply as esoteric interpretation this
Tau wheel or esoteric interpretation
naturally must always be done by or at
least supervised and taught by the
living Imam who is the only one that
holds the key to the quran's two
interpretations indeed the XI imams are
often seen as the original source of all
esoteric teachings in Islam including
many aspects associated with Sufism and
otherwise imams like jaffar assadek are
given a Central role as transmitters of
esoteric and occult knowledge and as
affirming the importance of tawil or
esoteric interpretation Jafar asada
himself is thought to have said quote
the book of God comprises four things
the statement set down
the implied purport the hidden meanings
related to these super sensible worlds
and the exalted spiritual doctrines
the imams are often given an almost
metaphysical role to play in reality
they are the poll around which the World
Turns and there can never be a time when
there is not an Imam living whether he
is Manifest or in hiding as he sometimes
is
the imams are sometimes associated with
the armor or command of God that
intermediary concept between God and
creation or at least between God and the
first creation which would be the
intellect they are indeed seen together
with the prophets whose religion they
represent as intermediaries between the
Believers and God as kind of
intercessory figures to which one can
turn to address God now some critics of
ismailism will often accuse them of
worshiping the imams of saying that the
Imam is God and directing prayers
towards the Imam this however isn't
entirely accurate arguably it is a
theological question that can be
approached from different perspectives
but in the general sense the ismailis do
not see the Imam as God or as an
Incarnation or manifestation of God
there have been some groups in history
considered extreme by the majority that
have given the imams an unusually
exalted position even seeing them as
things like the manifestation of God in
some way but for mainstream ismailism
and most ismailis in the world this is
not the case the Imam can sometimes be
described as a manifestation of the
light of God of his Noor and a mirroring
of the command of God he is never an
Incarnation or has any identity with God
as such he is not a mirror of God in
himself but a mirroring of the Divine
command armor and sometimes the first
intellect
and this makes a significant difference
remember the ismailis were very adamant
to keep God entirely Transcendent Beyond
any creaturely connections and so to
claim in some way that the Imam is God
or an incarnation of God or a mirroring
of God that would completely go against
that fundamentally Central aspect of
ismaili theologies which makes no sense
you can consult my earlier episode in
this series on the 12 verse she is for
more information about the role of the
imams in chiism more generally the imams
are the custodians the alcia of
Muhammad's Revelation and the carriers
and source of esoteric knowledge it is
only those initiated into the community
led by The Chew Imam of the time that
has access to the true interpretation of
Islam and of reality really this
emphasis on esotericism is common across
Shi Islam in general but particularly so
for the ismailis the ismailis have often
put a huge emphasis on the button right
the inner the hidden aspects of of the
Quran of Revelation and religion uh but
also the hidden aspect of reality you
know just the all these esoteric aspects
are hugely characteristic of ismailism
in particular so much so that many
people across history often people who
have criticized them also have referred
to these Smileys as the albatinia right
the people
can roughly translated as the esoterics
basically how does this show itself well
we have already seen some examples the
way that the ismailis interpret quranic
Concepts to be equivalent or actually
referring to much more abstract in this
case neoplatonic philosophical Concepts
or realities is one such example but
there's more every religious ritual or
practice such as prayer fasting or
pilgrimage have inner esoteric meanings
in the example of the daily prayers
says quote
the exterior meaning of ritual prayer is
the worship of God with the body by
advancing towards the Qibla of bodies
which is the Kaaba the house of God the
exalted in Mecca the esoteric
interpretation
of the ritual prayer is the worship of
God with the rational Soul by turning in
the Quest for knowledge of the book and
the law towards the equibla of spirits
which is God's house which is a house in
which God's knowledge resides the Imam
of Truth
each movement of the body in prayer as
well as all other aspects of it are
related to esoteric teachings and
numbers in relation to his smiley
teachings and this is also true of
quranic verses and stories we find many
examples across history of quranic
stories and and parts of the Quran that
are interpreted allegorically and
esoterically by various thinkers within
a smilism using the technique of tawil
right of esoteric interpretation another
one of the key figures in ismaili
history
was an Arabic scholar and jurist who
worked under some of the earliest
Fatimid kinif imams he will return in
our later discussion about jurisprudence
too but he was also a significant figure
when it comes to philosophy and the
doctrine of esoteric interpretation
in his work entitled assassil
foundations of esoteric interpretation
he offers definitions for how this
process works as well as some
fascinating examples quote almighty God
made the quran's external form zahid the
miracle of his messenger and its inner
meaning Barton the miracle of the imams
from the people of his household
it cannot be found with anyone but them
and none can produce the like of it save
them just as none can produce the like
of the external form of the book save
their grandfather Muhammad the messenger
of God only the imams from his progeny
can expound its inner meanings and this
knowledge is passed on and inherited in
their lineage and entrusted to them he
then goes on to interpret different
stories from the Quran in esoteric ways
the birth of Jesus one of the great
Messengers is taken to me in the
beginning of his dawa or Mission led by
the imams that succeed him furthermore
the story about job is interpreted in
the symbolic ways too according to this
reading job is one of the imams in the
prophetic cycle of Abraham responsible
for leading the dawah or mission of his
religion in this story though the
Pharaoh at the time has led job's
followers away from the True Religion
and the story of how the devil kills
job's family becomes a metaphor for this
quote the tawil of Iblis is Job's
adversary during this time his murdering
the children is his diversion of those
who had accepted jobs dawah the worms
are a symbol of those who responded to
jobs dawa and then betrayed him their
eating of his flesh refers to their
consumption of his knowledge though they
were never like him in kind or form we
see similar kinds of interpretations in
the writings of Nasir khusro
here the story of Noah and the Ark
contains the esoteric confirmation of
the imamet quote Noah's Ark is not a
thing of wood but the prophet's
household
Noah's flood is not of water but instead
of ignorance and waywardness even things
like the day of Resurrection hell and
Paradise are ultimately seen as
metaphors they are not literal places
but symbolic references to spiritual
states of the Soul quote if it is asked
what is Paradise we reply that it is a
world of spirits and a mind of the
lights
and if it is asked what is hell we say
that it is a mind of agonies and
torments if it is asked what the
Gathering is the day of judgment we
reply that it is the Assembly of
particular souls in the presence of the
Universal Soul notice thee very strong
neoplatonic features of these esoteric
interpretations these are just a few
examples of how taui or esoteric
interpretation and the Baton hidden
aspects of religion work according to
these Smileys all aspects of reality
have a zahr and a baton an outer
manifest part and an inner esoteric
Parts humans have an outer body and an
inner soul there is an outer Imam in the
world but also the inner Imam or guide
which is often identified with the or in
this case reason of human beings the
word is very difficult and it's used in
different ways as we've seen it is the
name for the metaphysical intellect but
also more general term for human reason
as it is used here
because reason has always played a major
role to his smiley thinkers religion
must be understood through the tool of
Reason through rational deduction and
correct understanding as taught by the
imams of course these Smileys would
criticize many other groups of Muslims
who they believed had fallen into
literalism and ignorance instead of
emphasizing the importance of reason and
investigation for understanding the
world and religion
reason and Revelation are in fact
compatible not only compatible but
intimately connected this can be seen
from the simple fact that the ismailis
have such a deep and developed
intellectual and philosophical tradition
and the different ways that they have
employed that and to some degree the
same can also be said for a smiley
Jewish Prudence indeed the ismaili
understanding of the Islamic law the
Sharia is also rather unique and
fascinating now these Smileys are often
accused of having abandoned the Sharia
or of having no Sharia at all and this
is not really true the ismailis do see
themselves very much as following the
Sharia of the Prophet Muhammad they seem
to have a different understanding of the
foundation of that law and the ways that
it can transform and change as a result
of that Foundation we must here again
stress the importance of the Imam the
imams or imamet plays such a major role
in all aspects of shiism including in
law and jurisprudence
having the only true access to the
esoteric meanings of religion at its
correct interpretation the imams are the
ultimate source of practice as well as
belief this is not to the detriment of
the Quran or the Sunnah of the Prophet
those two are still at the core of
ismaili practice but the imams embody
the Sunnah and the message of the Quran
it is they who know what its true
messages are and can thus interpret and
apply it to different circumstances when
we talk about the Sharia of the ismailis
we don't just mean law in the modern
Common Sense Sharia in Islam includes
all practical aspects of living from how
to pray how to treat other people how to
fast Etc is the Practical aspects of
religion simply put and on a smiley
jurisprudence was first clearly
formulated in the Fatimid era before
there was no systematized law in that
way these Smileys would have followed
the common practice of any land that
they found themselves in or simply
follow the rulings of the current Imam
but with the sudden access to political
power and no longer having to be in
hiding performing so-called takiya the
Smileys could now formulate their own
tradition of law this development is
primarily associated with a figure we've
already met in this discussion and khadi
Norman
he was a North African figure who
studied law history and philosophy and
at some point accepted the ismaili Creed
and started working for the fatimids he
worked as a chief Claudio judge and at
the central legal Authority for the
first four caliph imams particularly
under the rule of the khilif Imam Al
mahez and in collaboration with him he
wrote some of these Central works of
ismaili jurisprudence primarily a work
known as the daim al-islam the pillars
of Islam in these Works he established a
method of jurisprudence that is rather
unique and can appear very strict in
this ismaili law there is no room for HD
hat or the independent reasoning of
individual jurists as was common in
Sunni Islam this was in fact a great
Calamity that had led the sunnis down
the wrong path according to al-normal
and these Smileys he writes quote those
jurists follow their whims without
guidance from God and they produced new
rulings originating with themselves
regarding the religion of God they
contradicted the book of God and the
speech of the messenger of God instead
the only sources for a smiley practice
should be three the Quran the Sunnah of
the prophets and the rulings of the
imams The Scholar augustinos hilardo
writes quote the fatimids did not accept
the use of reasoning and deduction in
tafseed and firk because of the value
that the she is placed on the use of
sources
since the Imam worthy depository of our
learning it was in close collaboration
with him that the Supreme qadi in His
function as official faki of the dynasty
wrote treatises on FIP thus Al Norman
consulted al-muise regularly while
composing his main theological Works
himself said quote a claudi judge should
decide in accordance with the book of
God and what he does not find in the
book of God he should seek it in what is
established from the prophet of God and
the imams from his progeny if he has no
knowledge about it or that he does not
find it he should refer it to the Imam
and inquire from him about it and he
should not decide depending on his
individual judgment or analogical
deduction or discretionary preferences
this stands in great contrast to a
smiley attitude towards philosophy and
theology were Ackle or intellect reason
was very much encouraged right in terms
of law we see the opposite at least here
in the Fatimid era right nonetheless
this became kind of the standard for a
smiley jurisprudence going forward at
least in the Middle Ages even today the
taibi ismailis in particular still very
much base their jurisprudence on the
writings of Claudia Norman and the the
principles that he lays down in works
like the I am in Islam especially since
this branch of ismailism do not have a
living Imam present in the world today
that can guide them in terms of
questions of Law and practice as for the
majority of ismailis the so-called
nizaris which is the main focus of this
episode things are quite a bit different
because indeed the nissanis have had a
living present Imam from you know from
the beginning at least according to
themselves from Muhammad all the way
until today to return thus to our
historical narrative the crumbling of
the Fatimid State saw the division of a
smiley shiism into the taibis in Yemen
and eventually India and the nizadis
the nazaris managed to establish a new
kind of State in Iran and Syria under
the leadership of the very famous Hassan
as Sabah who led the community from the
mountain Fortress of alamut and became
famous for their political strategy of
sending out agents to assassinate their
opponents the inasalis of this period
were given the name assassins by later
chroniclers and has become very famous
since then among other things serving as
the basis for the Assassin's Creed
series of video games for more thorough
look into the nizadis of the alamut
period and the Assassins check out my
full episode dedicated to that topic but
eventually this period also saw the
emergence of new imams descendants of
the Imam Nazar who had been deposed as
Fatimid caliph and these imams in alamut
would establish some of the key features
of Nissan ismailism in particular one
very important concept for this group is
what is known as talim this is a
doctrine that essentially doubles down
on the imam's exclusive access to Divine
truth the Imam had absolute authority to
make new rulings and even to change
rulings by earlier imams because he had
after all perfected knowledge and can
reinterpret things according to the
needs of the time
in the words of the scholar khalilandani
quote the ismaili Imam of any given time
period has the full Authority and right
to interpret Islam Implement religious
laws Institute or abrogate religious
practices and give socio-political
guidance as he sees most appropriate for
the current circumstances even if that
guidance contradicts that of a prior
Imam and this certainly becomes relevant
in the alamut period when the Imam
Hassan Allah claimed that the kriyama or
Resurrection had happened
if you remember these Smileys believe
that there would come a kaim to
inaugurate the resurrection esoterically
understood to me in a time when the
truths or of the religion was revealed
to the community and they no longer had
to abide by the outer aspects of the
Sharia or Islamic practice that isn't to
say that they thus didn't have any
practices at all but that these
practices were more inwardly or
spiritually focused rather than physical
and that's precisely what Hassan did
although it seems that most ismailis
still practice The Irregular Islamic
rituals especially in Syria which was
somewhat isolated from the forges in
Iran but it was a significant shift the
nazadis had now entered a new era of
History where they had access to the
esoteric truths through the guidance of
the Imam but strangely only two imams
later under the imamit of jalaladin
Hassan this seems to have been reversed
instead jalaladin seems to have turned
towards sunism for a kind of
reconciliation
he told his followers to start
practicing the outer law again and even
invited Sunni Shafi Scholars to teach
them the practices of Sunni law so what
was going on here on the principle of
talim these rulings were largely
accepted by the community the Imam must
have had a good reason to do what he did
but his Smileys also generally see this
as a form of takiya the idea is that the
shiis can hide their identity and
outwardly seem and practice like sunnis
for example to avoid persecution
but why now all of a sudden the answer
probably lies in the oncoming invasion
of the Mongol armies Imam jalaladin
Hassan's reversal of the kriyama policy
and turned towards sunism was probably a
way through Takia to help unify the
Muslims in a general sense against the
incoming Mongols this didn't help too
much though because in 1256 the Mongols
managed to conquer alamots and all the
other Mountain fortresses destroying the
libraries and buildings there and even
executing the ruling Imam after this
time the history of nazare ismailism is
a bit more obscure and uncertain it is
clear that the community survived in
various locations but the Imam seemed to
have been in a long period of hiding
outwardly appearing As Leaders of a Sufi
order the inyamatullahi order while
keeping their true identity as ismaili
imams a secret that is until the
re-emergence of the imamit in the 19th
century with the Aga Khan after this the
imams of the nazari Smileys have been
this line of figures with the title Aga
Khan
their current Imam is Aga Khan IV or
Shah Karim al-hasani having a line of
imams throughout history and especially
considering the adoption of talim the
nazari Smileys have of course been very
varied as a result of this in terms of
practice and belief the legal presidents
of figures like Al Khali Norman while
important of course have not played as
major overall in his audience milism
because the living present imams have
always shaped and reshaped the
principles of ismaili practice in
different ways for example Aga Khan III
ended the period of takria and
reinstated the kriyama or Resurrection
but what are those practices on a more
concrete level ismaili practice involves
daily prayers just like for all Muslims
for the taibis this means the five Salah
prayers just like for sunnis and 12
rashids for the nazadis however this has
been replaced by a prayer called simply
the Dua which means a prayer and which
is done through three times a day rather
than five
the nezatis also tend to pray in a
building called the jamatrana rather
than in a mosque because the outer
ritualistic form of the muhammadan
Sharia has been deemed abrogated by the
nazarian moms meaning that the true
esoteric meanings of these practices
have been revealed they are often
interpreted or performed esoterically
this means that the nizadis don't have
to fast during Ramadan but should always
be in a state of esoteric fasting or
staying away from sin and bad behavior
they also don't have to do the
pilgrimage to Mecca but instead an
esoteric kind of pilgrimage but of
course they are allowed to and many do
still perform these traditional exoteric
practices of the religion charity or
zakat is also still important to
dinizaria Smileys and the current Imam
the Aga Khan is responsible for a lot of
charity work around the world the
nazaris pay their zakat to the Imam
rather than directly to charity and it
is then the responsibility of the Imam
to distribute that money to the benefit
of the community and for various
Charities around the world
the ismailis argued that this was the
function of the zakat originally a
religious tax pay to Muhammad and the
early caliphs and that it only later
developed into a kind of donation of
Charity in some historical research also
actually seemed to point in that same
direction since these Smileys are she is
they also perform many rituals that they
share with other branches of that
community in particular perhaps most
Central of these is the commemoration of
the third Imam al-hussein who was
martyred by umayyad forces in karbala in
680. this commemoration or period of
mourning takes place during the month of
Muharram and is known as Ashura during
Ashura various rituals are performed to
remember and mourn the death of Hussein
and his family the current community of
nizadi ismailis make up a unique form of
Islam in the world the leadership of the
AGA khans and the reunification of the
community happened only in the last
century or so
the current agar Khan as well as his
predecessor has become major players on
the world scene not only working to
unify the smiley Community but also
spearheading a number of international
organizations dedicated to charity
education and study there is the agacon
development Network that focuses on
developments in poor areas of Africa and
Asia there is also the Aga Khan
University with locations in places like
London and of course the institute for a
smiley studies dedicated to studying is
smiley history and belief in general the
Aga Khan has emphasized that Nissan
ismailis adhere to Modern and
Progressive values including things like
gender equality his understanding of the
Quran and the principles of Islam leads
him to this conclusion and the general
aspects of modernismilism is of course a
direct result of the doctrine of the
imamites and things like talim where the
Imam holds absolute power and authority
to determine religious principles the
ismaili she's make up a significant
Community Within in Islam today it is
estimated that there are around 15
million ismailis worldwide the vast
majority of these are nizadis but the
taibis are also in respectable numbers
perhaps between one to two million
adherents together they make up the
second largest branch of shiism within
the even larger religion of Islam as
we've seen from this historical overview
they have always represented a unique
form of Islam a very intellectually
philosophically and particularly
esoterically oriented form of that
religion it has produced some of the
greatest and most significant
philosophers and thinkers in Islamic
history and also been at the center of
some of the greatest Empires and
political movements in the history of
the Middle East they make up an
important part of the tapestry of the
Islamic World historically and today and
by now I hope you have become a little
more familiar with this fascinating
tradition you can check out some of my
earlier content on ismailism to dive
deeper into particular movements or
particular thinkers sometimes even
within that tradition I would like to
thank the scholar khalilandani for
assisting me with the script and with
this video it's been a huge help to have
an actual expert on on his smilism one
of the greatest experts on that
tradition in in the whole world
currently so I very much appreciate that
if anyone wants to know more about this
topic then you should definitely check
out khalil's research as well as a
YouTube channel that he has under his
own name khalilandani I will leave links
to that in the description and in the
comments also I would like to thank all
of my patrons of course who keep this
channel going without you I would never
be able to research and write all these
videos it really wouldn't be possible
without any of you so thank you all so
much for that if anyone else wants to
become a patron and support me
monetarily then I will leave links to
that also in the description of course
and that would be highly appreciated
really is the best way to support this
Channel and what I do so thank you all
for watching and I will see you next
time
[Music]
thank you